[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être là pour
notre rendez vous quotidien de débats et
de confrontation d'idées ses points de
vue avec comme chaque soir deux invités
bonsoir ferghana ziaya vous êtes
analyste en politiques publiques auprès
du think tank libéral l'iref vous êtes
aussi le délégué général de l'académie
des sciences humaines et puis guillaume
bernard est là aussi comme souvent
d'ailleurs dans c'est un tandem de choc
apprécié par vous tous chers internautes
guillaume bernard vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures et auteur comme
chacun le sait de la guerre à droite
aura bien lieu le mouvement dextrogyre
aux éditions desclée de brouwer je
propose de commencer par parler de la
publication de cette vidéo qui montre un
producteur longuement tabassé une par
trois policiers
la mise en ligne de ces images se
transforme en crise politique en tout
cas met sérieusement en difficulté le
gouvernement et en particulier
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur puisque ces images
choquantes sont concomitantes avec le
vote en cours d'une loi sur la sécurité
globale qui est supposé restreindre la
diffusion d'image mettant en scène des
policiers
je vous ai commencé par écouter gérald
darmanin il était l'invité hier soir du
journal de france 2 et le ministre de
l'intérieur a répondu par des chiffres
à cette interrogation pense de savoir si
ces images étaient des dérapages
l'individuel les limiter aux le reflet
d'une violence systémique
tu as vu il ya 3 millions d'opérations
de police par an 3 millions il ya sur le
site de signalement des faits que
peuvent rapprocher des citoyens aux
policiers 9500 signalement dans une
année sur trois millions d'opérations de
police sert qu'à 0 3 % de citoyens qui
considèrent que les policiers ont mal
cette réponse statistiques faga nazis
harry à au problème à ce qu'elle vous
paraît pertinente
il est toujours intéressant de rappeler
les faits s'ils sont vrais je les ai pas
vérifié mais je laisse ça aux
journalistes que que vous êtes
maintenant je ne suis pas certain que ça
suffise à disqualifier les critiques qui
sont adressées aujourd'hui non seulement
l'institution policière mais aussi au
gouvernement puisque vous l'avez dit 7
ces actes de violence intervient quand
même vraiment très particulier dans le
vote d'une loi qui est donc supposée
restreindre la liberté des uns et des
autres de filmer les policiers pour des
motivations qui restent ici controversé
puisqu'on voit pas très bien en fait la
valeur ajoutée d'un tel dispositif
puisque notre législation criminalise
déjà les attentions de nuire les appels
à la haine les appels à la violence les
appels au meurtre et tous ceux tous où
c'est cesser des lilas donc on se
demande la question mais finalement à
quoi bon pondre une loi qui semble
redondantes et qui introduit une
ambiguïté qui risque de créer de
l'insécurité juridique
parmi ceux qui filment les policiers ces
violences somme même si il serait
malvenu de faire un amalgame avec ces
violences a est tout tout tout les
policiers montre quand même que nous
nous devons rester attentifs à ce que
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont le bras armé
de l'état puisque c'est quand même le
rôle de la police restent dans leurs
justes attributions et c'est en ce sens
que la liberté de fini mais ces
policiers me semble indispensable parce
que notre tradition politique est fondée
sur un devoir de méfiance envers le
pouvoir
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a des
constitutions c'est la raison pour
laquelle on à la séparation des pouvoirs
montes tu disais que c'est une
expérience éternelle que tout homme août
a du pouvoir est porté à en abuser
donc il serait illusoire d'espérer
éradiquer les comportements criminels y
aura toujours des dérives y aura
toujours des incidents maintenant le
rôle de nos institutions c'est quand
même de faire en sorte de réduire la
probabilité que ces incidents arrivent
et saint pé que je crois de ne pas
restreindre ce contre-pouvoir aussi
qu'est la liberté pour les citoyens de
surveiller
les agents de police alors ça c'est beau
c'est pour la loi elle même et on y
reviendra mais je reviens sur ces images
duo bernard ou sur d'autres comme
l'évacuation de la place de la
république qui effectivement c'est fait
avec une forme de brutalité
est ce que c'est la police qui devient
violente parce que c'est l'ensemble de
la société et que donc en quelque sorte
il y aura une fatalité à sa
l'ensauvagement de la société écoutez
moi je suis j'ai pas de sympathie uni
d'hostilité de principe envers les
forces de l'ordre ont envers l'armée
simplement elles sont supposées
normalement assurer la sécurité et
l'ordre est donc évidemment quand ce
sont les forces de l'ordre qui font
preuve je dirais d'une violence
excessive
je pense que c'est choquant ça n'enlève
rien au poids de l'argument qui a été
présenté par le ministre qui est de dire
que c'est quand même a priori
l'exception mais enfin tout de même
depuis un certain temps on voit générer
des forces de l'ordre qui sont eux aux
ordres pour le coup du politique aux
ordres du gouvernement qui sont des
forces de l'ordre qui sont légalistes et
ça je ne l'oublient pas guy est bien
évidemment on fait preuve régulièrement
face à des manifestants les gilets
jaunes bien sûr y avait des casseurs
parmi les gilet jaune mais y avait pas
que des casseurs ils ont fait preuve de
la même violence vis-à-vis de tous bon
donc vis-à-vis des gilet jaune vis-à-vis
d'un certain nombre de citoyens qui
n'ont quand même pas grand chose à se
reprocher si ce n'est d'être mécontents
faire preuve d'une violence qui est
quand même me semble-t-il assez choquant
donc il faut prendre en considération
des proportions qui ont été évoqués par
par le ministre de l'intérieur
mais pour autant évidemment ce sont des
violences qui choque d'autant que dans
la sphère concernant le le producteur de
musique
il semblerait enfin moi c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit j'avoue que je ne connais pas
les tous les tenants et les aboutissants
de la sphère semblerait que au départ
c'est le fait qu'il ne portait pas de
masque qui faisait que il s'est retrouvé
dans cette situation là ça me paraît
totalement disproportionnée
bon voilà donc voilà j'ai une certaine
réticence a approuvé par principe
les actes des forces de police et sur
les noirs alors sur le fait de filmer
les policiers avant même d'en arriver à
la loi je voudrais si vous permettez que
je complète
j'aimerais en revanche qu'il y ait la
même indignation de la part de nos
politiques de vos confrères
eh bien lorsque vient ce sont des
policiers qui eux se font agresser
attaqué de manière inacceptable
lorsqu'on a des commissariats de police
qui sont qui représente qu on le veuille
ou non
l'ordre républicain qu'ils sont
délibérément pris pour cible lorsque des
pompiers des médecins se tombent dans
des guet-apens et alors là je suis au
regret de constater qu'il n'y a pas la
même indignation
donc moi bon en commande iran provincial
que je suis je mens vendéen n'est ce pas
eh bien je considère évidemment que il y
a une certaine réticence à avoir une
vis-à-vis de des forces qui représente
l'état et qui reste fidèle à la
puissance politique mais que pour autant
quand celle ci se font agresser il faut
avoir la même indignation alors il ya
votre question de coût très vite voilà
bien sûr la main sur les images il
paraît absolument indispensable qu'à
partir du moment où les images ne sont
pas trafiqué où elle reflète la réalité
qu'elles puissent être aient
visuellement diffusée est utilisée comme
mode de preuve mode de preuve
journalistique mode de preuve judiciaire
les internautes font écho aux propos à
tous les deux sur figaro live s'il
s'étonne de la différence d'indignation
entre ce qui s'est passé pour ce
producteur et pour les gilet jaune qui
ont été et bornier olympe dg sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous rappelle que les
policiers se sont trop énervé certes
mais depuis le temps qu'ils encaissent
les coups à jouer bell il ya la victime
quand même ça bon je trouve cet argument
mais il peut difficilement oui il faut
effectivement qu'on avait toutes les
violences mais moi je suis assez
dubitatif vis-à-vis de cette culture de
l'excusé un peu de droite qui consiste à
dire que le corps policier était prouvée
donc il faut comprendre siona qu'une ou
deux qui il ya un petit qui dérape non
ces dérapages ne sont jamais justifiable
ont des policiers aujourd'hui en effet
en prennent énormément mais enfin
l'exaspération elle existe aussi dans
les autres tous les autres corps de la
société ce n'est pas pour autant qu'on
se réveille tous un matin en voulant
tabassé un producteur de musique
romantique n'est pas son masque donc
babineau sur lefigaro.fr considère que
l'arsenal judiciaire est largement
suffisant et que cet article 24 et
inutile c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure
et puis si je qui ajoute dans le même
registre sur le figaro.fr que le
problème de fond c'est la justice qui ne
fait pas son travail et ce qui crée
énormément de tensions dans la société
je le disais au début gérald darmanin et
en est en première ligne dans ce dossier
il a proposé au premier ministre au
président la république la création
d'une commission pour réécrire ce fameux
article 24 qui réglemente la prise et la
diffusion d'image des policiers dans la
manifestation
et alors curieusement ça plaît pas du
tout aux parlementaires qui disait
attendait les lois c'est nous qui devons
les écrire je sais pas des commissions
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ferghana ziari je partage
l'indignation des parlementaires c'est à
dire que c'est une espèce de bras
d'honneur qui qui est qu'ils aient fait
la démocratie parlementaire alors oui on
rétorquera toujours que in fine et ce
sont les parlementaires qui décident
s'ils votent ou non la loi dont ils ont
le choix d'accepter ou non les
modifications de cette commission mais
j'avoue ne pas comprendre le geste et ça
c'est quand même une manière étrange de
communiquer alors même qu'on fait un
procès en autoritarisme à un
gouvernement et qui va interdire la
plupart des gens de de filmer
les policiers on va contourner un
instrument de la démocratie
parlementaire pour pour passer en force
bruce est désastreux sur le plan de la
communication que de procéder ainsi les
experts aux questions c'était
normalement le conseil d'état qui a lu
le projet de loi qui a donné un avis le
secrétariat général du gouvernement qui
normalement a participé à la rédaction
les cabinets ministériels qui sont là
pour faire le travail et donc il
faudrait revoir la copie or il aurait
droit à une à une nouvelle à une
nouvelle possibilité tandis que les
autres vient d'aider que leur
proposition est bien sont rejetés et
bien il ne faudrait pas les ne faudrait
pas les robes annoncé cesser c'est
ubuesque jeu ou tubes nous dit le fautif
c'est gérald darmanin il faudra enlever
cet article 24 je précise que 55 24
il doit être réécrit mais que le
ministre a expliqué qu il y tenait qu il
ne faudra donc pas l'enlever 2 du projet
de loi
et puis on vous a posé la question sur
twitter acheter moins de vue gérald
darmanin petit se maintenir à son poste
de ministre de l'intérieur
55 8% des votants répondent non sagana
diaries est ce que c'est le ministre qui
est en difficulté lui même là vous
croyez au c'est quand même un paradoxe
où il était supposé représenter l'ailé
droite de ceux de ce gouvernement en
position de force
et puis là il s'est un peu pris les
pieds dans le tapis je ne crois pas que
gérald darmanin alors willy les
responsables des forces de l'ordre qui
doit rendre des comptes effectivement
sur aujourd'hui des dérives de la sfio
policière mais à trop se focaliser sur
la personne même de gérald darmanin je
pense qu'on prend le risque d'occulter
peut-être la dimension institutionnelle
du problème est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
problème de d'incitation et de
responsabilité du corps policier
indépendamment finalement de celui qui
est à la tête du ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui ces débats là ne
concerne pas uniquement la france par
exemple aux états unis il ya en ce
moment un débat sur ce qu'ils appellent
eux l'immunité qualifiée d' immunité
qualifier c'est quoi c'est cette
institution qui permet finalement à
l'immunité collective c'est pas l'un
c'est l'immunité qualifiée
c'est un dispositif
juridique qui lorsqu'un policier comme
une bavure et bien permet en fait de
ceux de se défausser sur l'état sur le
contribuable qui va rembourser donc les
les plaignants qui se plaignent des
dommages infligés par les policiers dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions donc il y
avait hier n'y at il pas ici un problème
de responsabilité civile des policiers à
a interrogé tout simplement pour
conférer dans la police de meilleures
incitations peut-être à être plus
diligent vis-à-vis de ceux qui sont
censés servir et protéger
je pense que le problème est ici plus
que dans la personne de gérald darmanin
parce que je ne crois pas que ce soit
une affaire personnelle
c'est une affaire institutionnelle
puisque autre chose à mon avis un
sondage paru il ya quelques minutes que
bernard indique que 74% des français ont
dit être favorable à l'évacuation des
migrants de la place de la république
c'est le reflet d'une demande d'ordre
qui est assez général d'une inquiétude
des français face à la montée de la
sécurité au terrorisme le paradoxe est
que l'homme qui est supposé incarner sa
et fragilisés comme commence à se faire
votre avis comment est ce que gérald
darmanin a pu se retrouver dans ce dans
cette position où est ce que c'est la
cohérence d'un certain nombre de ses
positions me semble-t-il si elle vous
avez raison de dire que healy a
incontestablement une majorité de gens
qui aujourd'hui sont à condition qu'on
les interroge sans marquer la
proposition par une étiquette politique
c'est l'action lizin si on les interroge
en aveugle sur le principe il ya une
majorité de gens qui sont pour
effectivement un retour à l'ordre et en
particulier concernant les questions
d'immigration d'identité etc
mais pour autant gérald darmanin et bien
ils essayent je dirais tous azimuts
d'attirer à lui un spectre politique
pour se rendre encore plus politiquement
contournable il va
en algérie se prosterner devant les
tombes des faits du fln et puis en même
temps il est supposé pour son aile
droite effectivement essayé de montrer
qu'il est ferme face à l'immigration
clandestine
je crois que au bout d'un certain temps
l'incohérence est bien politique ça
finit par se voir
il est certain que je suis d'accord avec
fergane il n'est pas directement
responsable
évidemment des actes de violence qui ont
été commis par certains policiers
le problème c'est qu évidemment ça ça
monte en puissance puisque d'aucuns
disaient que si jamais jean castex était
en difficulté bien il pourrait peut-être
devenir un autre possible de matignon
pour l'instant évidemment sa progression
politique ne me semble un peu freiné
parce que pour arriver à matignon il
faut évidemment non pas être totalement
consensuel mais il faut être capable je
dirais de d'avoir un spectre politique
assez large et là en l'occurrence
et bien il s'est pris les pieds dans le
tapis des deux dernières remarques de
nos internautes merci à vous de réagir
avec autant de deux d'énergie et
d'engagement nicole 06 qui nous dit stop
avec les commissions par l'excavation
c'est évidemment une réponse à cette
proposition faite par le gouvernement de
réécrire par des experts cet article 24
c'est aux assemblées de faire ce travail
estime nicole 0,6 et puis archos guy sur
lefigaro.fr dans toutes les corporations
il ya des personnes douteuses on les met
en exergue dans la police mais on les
ignore dans la justice
et puis babineau sur figaro.fr encore
darmana était censé incarner un nouvel
ancrage sur le régalien
c'est un échec pour l'instant je vous
propose de passer à un autre sujet plus
plus économique peut être même
sociétales comme on dit aujourd'hui avec
les confinements successifs le
télétravail a explosé les partenaires
sociaux sont d'ailleurs parvenus à un
accord pour essayer d'organiser un petit
peu tout ça dans les relations entre les
employeurs et les salariés la cfdt était
l'un des signataires de cet accord
laurent berger son patron était ce matin
sur france info et lui explique que le
télétravail on en prend pour longtemps
on a réussi un accord qui est signé par
quatre organisations syndicales et trois
organisations patronales pour donner un
cadre
négociations dans les entreprises sur le
télétravail trop tard c'est pas trop
tard tu as he oui mais déjà il arrive et
et vous savez le télétravail ça va durer
très très longtemps pas simplement aux
situations exceptionnelles comme
aujourd'hui mais en situation pérenne
parce que on est rentré je crois dans
une nouvelle ère concernant le
télétravail donc cet accord il est
vraiment bienvenu alors le faire je vous
entend réagir dans vous croyez pas que
l'ère du télétravail est arrivé je n'y
crois pas un instant alors c'est vrai
qu'au début il ya eu un espèce
d'engouement une espèce d'engouement
pardon national parce que on saisit que
le bureau étant un lieu un peu aliénant
avec l'autorité patronale il ya un
chacun et retrouver une espèce
d'autonomie d'indépendance en
travaillant depuis chez soi je vous
coupe deux secondes 2 c'est exactement
ce que vous nous dites écoute et julia
de funès c'est une philosophe qui sort
qui s'intéresse à l'organisation du
travail que les internautes de point de
vue connaissent bien et elle dit presque
la même chose que vous vous allez voir
pour moi c'est une libération
psychologique énorme vous les
entreprises sont des grands blocs de
verre transparent visible on est visible
en permanence
donc il suffit de savoir visible pour
agir comme si nous étions vus donc on
est en représentation permanente on est
on est donc dans une forme de
théâtralité humaines de comédie humaine
qui disparaît modérément mais qui
disparaît quand même un peu plus en
télétravail où seule la performance seul
de livrables compte alors la différence
entre julia de funès et vous c'est que
j'ai étudiée celle trouve que c'est un
progrès le télétravail et vous pas
forcément je pense que les gens vont
vite déchanter c'est à dire que alors je
sais pas à quel point l'opinion de mes
proches et représentative mais j'ai
quand même l'impression que il ya une
envie
de revenir au bureau chez beaucoup
beaucoup de gens parce que on se rend
compte que le travail
le bureau n'est pas seulement le lieu de
l'autorité c'est aussi un lieu de
sociabilité et donc le risque avec des
travailleurs qui sont à distance le
risque de cette société des écrans
interposés
c'est finalement que les relations
sociales soient soit soit altérée donc
moi je pense que ça va rester tant qu'on
n'aura pas un vaccin en réalité ce qui
va déterminer le retour à la normale
c'est une campagne de vaccination de
masse quand un vaccin sûr et efficace
sera sur le marché mais je ne crois pas
du tout en cette nouvelle ère du
télétravail toutes les grosses
entreprises qui disaient on va vendre
nos bureaux on va faire travailler nos
collaborateurs revienne sur la décision
parce qu'ils se rendent compte que mon
père en productivité que les
travailleurs sont beaucoup moins motivés
parce qu'il n'y a plus du tout cet
esprit communautaire cet esprit de corps
au site il fait qu'une entreprise est
agréable à intégrer ou non
donc je pense qu'on va tous très vite
déchanté sur la qualité du télétravail
et sur le la bienveillance en tout cas
de ce mode de 2,7 de ce fonctionnement
la bio mara en raison de la pandémie
vous avez été amené à délivrer vos
courant en distance yale comme on dit
aujourd'hui avec ces vous atroce donc
via via une caméra comment ça se passe
avec vous étudiants est ce que c'est est
ce que c'est un bon système
ce que vous avez envie que ça se
pérennise
non j'ai pas trop envie qui
effectivement ce soit systématisée et
généralisée il est bien évident que pour
l'enseignant c'est plutôt confortable de
pouvoir travailler depuis chez soi
et puis ça favorise effectivement la
présence à la maison donc la vie
familiale
d'un certain point de vue ça n'est pas
nécessairement désagréable bien mais
pour autant il est bien évident que pour
ce qui me concerne pour ce qui concerne
les enseignants le l'enseignement à
distance c'est extrêmement dur de deux
points de vue d'abord c'est
épuisant parce que comme on ne sent pas
la réaction de l'amphithéâtre eh bien je
crois qu'on en fait beaucoup plus pour
essayer d'attirer l'attention des
étudiants en est à fond tout le temps
exactement
et puis on peut moins se permettre je
dirais des modulations de par le des
petites blagounettes qui ne font rire
que nous mais enfin qui permettent quand
même de détendre l'atmosphère
bon c'est évident que on est beaucoup
plus au taquet pour parler familièrement
parce qu'on a besoin d'essayer de
vraiment attirer l'attention il ne sent
pas comment réagit l'amphithéâtre et
puis d'un autre côté effectivement c'est
épuisant aussi je crois tout simplement
pour les étudiants parce que le fait
d'être seul de ne pas avoir l'effet
d'entraînement de l'amphithéâtre le fait
d'être toujours devant un écran et bien
au final il me semble que ça allait
mieux que ça les pénalisait de lampes mm
mais pas véritablement de de se
concentrer
mais au delà même de mon cas particulier
où des cas de du cas des enseignants
je crois qu'il faut quand même
s'interroger sur le principe même
le principe c'est que il ya déjà tout un
ensemble de métiers qui ne pourront pas
être considérés comment dire qu'ils vont
pas travailler par le télétravail
évidemment enfin les artisans les
commerçants
je crois que il faut quand même un tout
petit peu raison garder il ya un
deuxième élément c'est que finalement on
nous dit que le bureau où l'université
ou là où l'on travaille usines et c'est
un lieu de surveillance mais par le
biais du numérique on peut peut-être
tout autant voire peut être plus
surveillés les salariés de l'autorité ne
disparaît pas mais moi je crois qu elle
ne disparaît pas et qu'elle est
peut-être même plus oppressante
peut-être plus susceptibles d'être
présente encore et puis il ya un
troisième point qui me paraît très
important là c'est le provincial qui
vous parle provincial mais qui se
déplace
assez régulièrement pour des colloques
pour le figaro et bien si vous réduisez
une personne dans son travail au
télétravail
vous allez immédiatement réduire comme
une peau de chagrin son réseau social
c'est que elle aura comme et bien
capital social aurait dit pierre
bourdieu je vais extrait de le citer
devant feria pour l'énerver
mais elle n'aura comme capital social
que ce qu'elle aura acquis au moment où
elle va rentrer dans le travail et après
elle sera dénué de relations sociales
lui permettant d'élargir son horizon et
donc par conséquent les riches
pourraient ces riches et les pauvres
vont rester pour votre bon de salluste
dans la folie des grandeurs on l'aurait
dit c'est ça et donc je crois que ça
représente quand même une vraie
difficulté
il ya un risque d'enfermement d'un
certain nombre de personnes en
particulier évidemment dans les villes
moyennes de province
et une fois n'est pas coutume je me
permets de vous corriger a laissé un
tout petit peu puisque vous avez le
respect des grands auteurs don salluste
dit précisément les riches c'est fait
pour être très riches et les pauvres au
travail voilà nos internautes sont assez
partagés sur le sujet savoir si le
télétravail va devenir ou non la norme
en france 53 26 % des votants répondent
non et
puis voici quelques points de vue celui
de 6 ce qui est très présent aujourd'hui
qui le dit le télétravail demande une
importante rigueur dans son organisation
c'est vrai pendant pas pour réussir à ne
pas mélanger le personnel professionnel
jean michel marques sur lefigaro.fr
estime que le télétravail est une
évolution tout à fait naturel
et puis peut-on et puis benjamin rego
naisy sur youtube qui nous dit peut tous
en profiter pour réfléchir au partage du
travail en présentiel alors là c'est un
autre sujet effectivement le partage du
travail
moi j'étais un peu surpris par votre
réponse fergane parce que je pensais
qu'en tant que libéral vous alliez
apprécier la liberté que donne le fait
de travailler à distance et que donc de
pouvoir mieux organiser son temps d'être
en quelque sorte - dans une relation de
dépendance
vous pensez comme guillaume qu'au
contraire le la le liens de sujétion
numérique est plus fort que tous les
autres
dans un premier temps moi je suis pas
pour forcer tout le monde à aller au
bureau ou télé de marais donc je reste
lilly rush sur ce pont là si les gens
veulent
préfère t travailler et ne pas aller au
bureau très bien moi je n'ai absolument
rien à redire pour paris c'est que cette
préférence social est très faible et que
quand la crise sanitaire sera terminée
les gens se rueront au bureau et ne
resteront pas chez eux parce que dans un
premier temps il n'est pas vrai que le
lien de suggestions disparaît un salarié
doit rendre des comptes met d'ailleurs
même un indépendant en tant
qu'indépendant on doit rendre des
comptes à une cliente est donc il n'ya
jamais n'est jamais complètement
autonome sur le marché d'emploi auront
toujours des comptes à quelqu'un à des
degrés depuis plus ou moins à plus ou
moins fort en revanche ce qu'on perd
véritablement avec le télétravail et je
rejoins pas ce que dieu m'a dit c'est
vraiment le lien social
et c'est cette plus-value là qui
disparaît qui fait que le travail
devient mon avis plus aliénant donc je
suis plus sceptique en effet quand au
disco qui disent que le télétravail est
une sorte de libération
le risque c'est une atomisation mon avis
du corps social qui peut contenter
quelques personnes quelques misanthrope
mais je ne suis pas certain que tous les
travailleurs français le soit mais on
proscrit de la subordination
l'atomisation quand vous avez une série
de personnes de subordonner de salariés
et qui sont individuellement en relation
avec l'autorité avec l'autorité et bien
vous pouvez d'autant plus exercer cette
autorité sur eux que lorsqu'ils sont
réunis ensemble et qu'ils constituent
une équipe
moi je suis très suspicieux vis-à-vis de
la supposée libération que représente le
télétravail et puis encore faut-il que
ce l'était le travail se fasse dans de
bonnes conditions
en règle générale en province on a des
habitations plus grande que en région
parisienne dans les grandes métropoles
et enfermer quelqu'un pour quelle est sa
vie et privés et professionnels dans le
même lieu
c'est se décharger quand même d'une
responsabilité vis-à-vis d'eux qui me
paraît inacceptable
il ya comme un argument très concret
vous disiez parler des grandes
métropoles mais dans les grandes
métropoles mais aussi beaucoup de temps
pour aller à son travail et donc
permettre de gagner je crois que c'est
une heure vingt par jour en moyenne de
temps de passer par les transports c'est
quand même une salle une forme de
libération mais justement pourquoi les
gens se donne-t-il la peine d'aller au
bureau ou pas le choix c'est je pense
pas qu'il y avait cette obligation
d'aller au bureau avant la crise et à
dire que les salariés et les employeurs
pouvaient déjà s'arranger vous pouvez se
mettre d'accord sur le fait de
travailler ou non par le télétravail
n'est pas une invention de la pandémie
de colo 8 19 mai c'est
jusqu'à maintenant la norme était fait
d'aller au bureau je pense que ce n'est
pas totalement arbitraire et qu'il ya
des raisons pour lesquelles les gens
préfèrent se déplacer plutôt que de
rester chez eux à confondre vie privée
vie professionnelle ne pas pouvoir
travailler parce que le conjoint est au
téléphone tout le temps et donc on a du
mal à exercer notre notre notre activité
sans empiéter sur celle de l'autre donc
je pense que c'est cette tradition là
elle n'est pas arbitraire et je suis pas
certain qu'elle disparaîtra et compris
après la pandémie
le télétravail a beaucoup davantage de
10am à flasher sur youtube pour certains
mais à long terme le contact social est
indispensable d'autant et ça c'est
vraiment un argument fort vous disiez
quand on donne ses cours à distance on
ne sent pas l'autre et il ya aussi le
fait que
quand on est à une quand on est en
présence physique de l'autre on peut
détecter beaucoup de choses y compris
d'ailleurs des signaux faibles des
doutes sur des problèmes qui peuvent se
poser qui n'ont pas encore été
complètement exprimés et que le l'écran
créer une distance
id empêche que c'est peut-être une
tendance très lourde que vous le
souhaitiez ou non puisque vous êtes
plutôt contre tous les deux les écrans
ont déjà envahi complètement le la vie
privée les relations sociales avec ses
réseaux qu'on appelle sociaux évidemment
la culture avec le développement des
plateformes comme netflix est donc
maintenant le travail tout ça est assez
cohérent non tout ça est assez
je souhaite être inquiétant la colère je
crois pas que ce soit une opposition
c'est complémentaire
le fait qu'on soit dans une société
numérique dans les l'absolument en rien
la valeur ajoutée des contacts physiques
les bars ne seront pas déserter demain
au motif que tout le monde peut faire
des apéros zoom ou des amiraux skype
comme on l'a fait pendant le confident
donc je pense que en dépit des avantages
des écrans il ya une plus value il ya
une valeur ajoutée à se retrouver sans
écran interposé et je crois que c'est un
cc c'est grâce à cette plus value que
les gens vont continuer à travailler
pour concevoir et puis je crois qu'il ya
une question d'âge à partir duquel on
commence à fréquenter ces techniques
c'est à dire qu'évidemment haut lorsque
l'on peut s'en détacher parce que l'on
n'a pas toujours été pris tu dirais par
ses habitudes sociales et bien on peut
on peut on peut s'en libérer tandis qu
évidemment je crains qu'il y ait un
risque pour les plus jeunes générations
d'être d'en être totalement dépendante
je ne vous cacherai pas qui
effectivement je préfère faire cours en
amphithéâtre et faire des réunions par
le biais de l'informatique ce qui permet
de faire autre chose pendant la réunion
que de suivre que de que de la suivre ça
j'avoue que j'y trouve effectivement à
d'intérêt mais reconnaissons le ce n'est
pas dans l'efficacité de la réunion que
je vais nécessairement tout
toute mon attention et bien sûr cette
confidence toute personnelle ça signera
la fin de cette émission merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis et bien sûr
point de vue revient lundi prochain pour
une nouvelle semaine d'actualité
merci
[Musique]